happy birthday thanks man
Rob Kardashian turns 32 and his daughter
threw him an epic bash what a musician
Rob's sister Chloe revealed on her
Instagram story on Saturday that Rob's
two-year-old daughter dream wanted to
throw him a birthday party so they
celebrated with a st. Patrick's Day
themed bash it looks like leprechauns
threw up in here I love it the entire
Kardashian family was seen in attendance
Kanye and North played in the balloons
while Kylie's a one-year-old daughter
stormy was rocking her st. Paddy's green
I got our green on the former reality
stars sisters also took to social media
to celebrate their Bros special day
[Music]
Chloe posted several throwback shots of
the pair calling him her BFF and one of
her favorite human beings Kim took to
the gram to share this sweet snap
praising Rob as a dad writing in part I
was looking through old pictures and all
of the amazing memories came up my best
memories though are you as a dad and
seeing what an amazing person you have
become you have to worry about Rob and
how you could be strong and better for
you and now your baby never a dull
moment while Rob's mom Kris Jenner
posted a few throw backs as well with
the caption you are such a huge part of
my heart you have the most beautiful
soul and I love you more than you can
ever imagine you are such a wonderful
amazing caring and loving daddy and it's
a joy to watch you with your baby dream
at the end of the day the family stands
together
were united we're there for each other
and week there's a lot of love there
[Music]